it's hard to remember now but Robert
Muller Special Counsel investigation
began as a probe into Russian collusion
you'll recall the story we were told
then a foreign power influenced the
outcome of our election we've got to
figure out how exactly that happened and
determine if any American citizens were
involved in that plot once that the
whole thing was sold to the rest of us
and by the way some Republicans on
Capitol Hill still seem to believe
that's what it's about nobody ever
accused them of genius but to the rest
of us it's pretty obvious what's going
on and to make it even clearer Robert
Miller just hired a new prosecutor the
other day once again another Hillary
donor there doesn't seem to be a single
Republican on robert muller staff in an
evenly divided country what are the odds
of that well 100 percent actually once
you understand the purpose of this whole
exercise what you're looking at is a
political campaign waged with guns and
subpoenas and the surveillance power of
the US government in conventional
politics the kind we used to have
Republican candidates Democratic
candidates run against each other one
wins one loses sometimes someone retires
that's how we used to conduct it now
lives are being destroyed forever
people going bankrupt others are heading
to prison well today a federal judge
finally tried to slam the brakes on all
of this District Court Judge TS Ellis
erupted in a way that federal judges
rarely do the accused Muller and his
team of granting themselves quote
unfettered power to wage politics rather
than a legitimate criminal investigation
quote you don't really care about Paul
Manafort bank fraud the judge said you
really care about what information mr.
Manafort can give you to lead to mr.
Trump and an impeachment or whatever it
was a shocking moment precisely because
what he said was entirely true and yet
somehow the Muller investigation
continues tonight leaving lives in its
wake Muller's latest target according to
recent news reports is longtime
Republican political consultant Roger
stone Roger stone joins us right now
Roger thanks for coming on so according
to NBC and I want to read you a quote I
know you're familiar with you are quote
one of the top subjects of the
investigation into pretend
collusion between Moscow and the Trump
campaign NBC says Robert Muller is quote
focusing intensely on you what about you
has triggered the scrutiny of Muller
what crime is he suggesting you
committed well Tucker perhaps it's my
advocacy of the election of Donald Trump
in my 40-year friendship for him and my
role in advocating and and working for
his election I like to call this the
Russian collusion delusion so far he has
turned up no evidence of collusion by
the Russian state I certainly am not
involved in any conspiracy or
coordination or collusion with the
Russian state I think this is a fairy
tale left-wing conspiracy theory that is
the basis for a rogue operation to undo
the results of the last election but
meanwhile it's an actual active criminal
investigation and according to NBC the
CNBC story Muller is looking at you
because of your longtime friendship it
suggests with Rick Gates who was the
associate of Paul Manafort who who was
indicted and pled to a number of
felonies it said he was an intern in an
office that you had 30 years ago and
that you had repeated contact with him
it didn't say about what so what he said
is that true well our longtime
relationship I think the first time I
met him was in 2016 I don't believe you
worked at Black Manta Fortin stone back
in the 80s he evidently was an intern in
the successor firm after I left the CNBC
story specifically says that the special
counsel is focused on our dinners with
an S I only know of one dinner attended
by many the purpose of which was to
discuss the apportionment of the New
York delegates to the Republican
National Convention to try to make sure
there were a few Trump supporters on the
delegation after Donald Trump swept the
New York primary there also according to
CNBC focusing on my meetings with mr.
gates at Trump Tower at which there were
absolutely none
this whole thing is based on conjecture
speculation a supposition but no facts
my contacts with Rick Gates during the
campaign were minimal and innocuous I
hate to say this but I think the source
for the CNBC story I think they got both
shift as some Republicans now say well
speaking of congressman Adam Schiff the
ranking member of the House Intelligence
Committee he said in before the Congress
and his remarks were echoed by Hillary
Clinton that you knew ahead of time the
Hillary campaign chairman John Podesta
gmail account had been hacked by the
Russians and its contents were gonna
become public did you know that how did
you know that if so and why would he say
that that is categorically false it's a
shame that congressman Schiff is allowed
to hide before behind his congressional
immunity even the final report of the
House Intelligence Committee truncates
and incorrectly quotes my now iconic
tweet I said the Podesta's referring to
both John and Tony's time in the barrel
will come referring to entirely public
information published in the Panama
papers early in 2016 that exposed their
shady business dealings in Russia
context Paul Manta Ford's business
dealings in the Ukraine were being fed
to the the media at the time I thought
it only fair that the facts regarding
the Podesta's come forward nowhere did I
say that his email would be hacked
I had no advanced knowledge of that hack
just while we're on it to be clear I
never received any material from
WikiLeaks or Asajj I never passed
anything on to Donald Trump and I never
had any contact with the Russian state
and received nothing from them including
allegedly hacked emails as I said
earlier this is a left-wing conspiracy
theory promulgated by people like Robby
Mook and others Adam Schiff surfer boy
Eric SWA well they hide behind their
congressional immunity and they run a
campaign of smear innuendo
personal attack but this isn't just a
public relations campaign waged by
members of Congress against Republicans
there's a criminal component to it so
news reports have said that you were the
subject of a FISA warrant in other words
the federal government was reading your
email tapping your phone falling around
whatever was surveilling you using our
intel in law enforcement agencies do you
believe that's true well the New York
Times reported on January 20th of 2017
that I was the subject of a FISA warrant
what their probable cause would be is
hard to understand other than my strong
support for Donald Trump again I wish
this were just a public relations value
I have the project for democracy and
Obama blessed front suing me in the
District of Columbia what's their claim
oh then I worked with the Russians to
hack the DNC email and gave the
information to WikiLeaks they don't
produce any evidence or proof they
produce a theory now the Democratic
National Committee has filed a virtually
mirror lawsuit in the courts in New York
it costs hundreds of thousands of
dollars just to move to dismiss these
suits I'm facing investigation costume
well between the House Intelligence
Committee the the project democracy or
project for democracy lawsuit the early
rumblings of the house apartment the
Senate Intelligence and Judiciary
Committee a lawsuit in Miami from a
[ __ ] named miles Kwok which is a
total crock of chef and the prospect now
of a probe by mr. Muller in the
non-existent communications and
machination z-- with mr. gates I could
be looking at legal fees of up to a
million dollars anybody who wants to
help can go to stone Defense Fund calm I
have no choice
to go on Infowars when I do a Daily Show
to come here and beg for money to
protect the solvency and the college
education of my grandchildren you better
be a Russian agent I
mean it I hope you're a Russian agent
otherwise this really is a miscarriage
and an assault on the Civil Liberties of
all of us and I wish to left agree with
me on that Rodgers don't thank you